still rocking that katarina who um back
in season three a lot of people said
katarina is dead she is done for uh
season four got a few boss record down
for one is kind of right a new low from
harrier so let's see
uh if gallander can take advantage of
that going up against kunimitsu in
bumblebee i did wonder about gurlando
obviously we know him as playing cat but
he plays so many different characters
he's got a phenomenal king as well i
wasn't expecting genre from yeah
nice stuff great aggression
that's something there's a bumpy just a
very very aggressive in your face game
plan but oh late on the punisher and
down forward see
if bomb will begin he's very hard to
stop a nice whiff punish there from
galander we saw that last we'll carry
earlier we're going to see katarina wall
carry just shy there
i mean all all glad needs is one note to
go to but nice nice down before that
beats the one one two great start from
bumblebee
good knowledge there from bumblebee
galander already having to fight his way
back afford four four punished nice
i'm glad someone told me bumblebee's
name was bumblebee before because before
i used to say
right that's that's what i thought the
name was until someone said no that's
that's bumblebee i was like oh okay
no break from the one throw there
finishes it again
nearly
oh nice guaranteed stomp there very nice
there from galander great start and one
launch to the wall he will win this
round
because katarina's race drive is kind of
crazy it is and he's looking for it
but now he is at the wall
nice we're punished for the 2-2
oh and they're set three good i'm
looking for a down back three there a
bit risky didn't work out i'm being
prime position right now
now the rules are taken away oh but nice
firm there from boom
boom golando is in a real pickle right
now looking like he's in big trouble
yeah and the set two catches the spring
and that's gonna be the round
will be and that was just so stylish i
feel like tekken players if you can end
away stylish like that just do it all
the time please i just looks nice um
anyway great good option what a good
option as well finishing with that and
wow that went quick
galander needs to change it up big time
and you know i don't with a player like
galander the character is never going to
be the problem he will need to adapt to
the player and what the opponent's doing
i think what i'm just seeing him more
than anything is just
he's not playing against kunimitsu
very well
which is a bit obvious to say losing
down losing a 3-0 but like he's just you
know stuff like two to two he's not
ducking the third hit he's just taking
the string he's weighing for the last
hit you know the cartwheel academics is
down four three plus four which is such
a such a strong neutral controlling tool
she can go into back turned into or stay
in front of you kind of really can't
really react to and then she has the
back turn mixed up or she stays in your
face i think she's actually plus i think
it's minus two um which isn't even that
bad for kunimitsu you know she has stuff
like 4-1
um which is jails both his high tracks
to a weak side like uh glenda just isn't
playing around any of this really well
um you know i one thing i like that he's
doing is when bumblebee approaches in
set he is ducking most of the time like
i said earlier there isn't really a mid
you should really be scared of in set
maybe block the set three you get a full
launch so it's worth the risk uh in my
opinion um but other than that he's just
he's he's come close he's come close
taking some rounds but bumblebee has
just managed to clutch out uh every
single time so you know we're going to
see some adaptations here from galander
and i like it it's also random select he
he knows exactly it was just the way he
was playing in that game it wasn't the
character it wasn't the stage's fault he
just needs to make some adaptations and
i think he's ready for it
we will find out golana does need to
change it up he probably needs to slow
down ever so slightly as well and do you
think the bumblebee won that three-nil
and didn't really need to put in any
full crouch mix-ups at all didn't need
to go big didn't need to go too big
anyway
i just needed to see garland to put out
that brick wall because bumpy like i
said earlier is someone who wanted when
he's on the front four when he gets
going as all the momentum in his favor
is very hard to stop and you see here
trying to get going we need to see
we need galada to force bumblebee to
play defense but that's not going to
happen in this round anyway
oh i like it drops the combo early
because he didn't want to put uh
gallander in rage
nice choice there is the two two two and
atlanta tries to challenge after that
and bumpy four rounds straight right now
looking the much stronger player right
now in this particular matchup goodness
the two string just the option select
there the jump over the back the jump
over
one will be there everything's working
out okay this should be a start here for
galander
again not ducking the two to not ducking
the third hit
this is poor right now for galander but
not the best would punish their single
hop kick
and the down for bumby five rounds
straight right now gallander doesn't
know what to do
is this going to be a double no round
brown no galander needs to change it up
this is a good start
exactly what you need we need to see
golando force bombay to play defense but
just to messes up the combo there and
now look back to the wall almost in the
corner full crash down four three what's
the follow up two two two
it's not the worst there's four crashed
down four three in the whole game as
well it's gone
oh my face the
three plus four just like that bumblebee
would take it six rounds straight
over gallander that was just a kuni
mitsu master class right there and golan
milan is not done yet we've had a lot of
loose matches but this is our first
winners match of the day so glenda will
just move down into the losers bracket
but you know bumblebee moves on into the
winners final